>>> Tonight, new video just in
to out front, the moment a
soldier shoots a Russian jet out
of the sky.
Holding a sure fas to air
missile launcher and fires twice
and you see the entire recoil
turning away and then you will
see the jet's wreckage still
burning.
You can appear -- you can see
what appears to be a white
parachute.
We don't know what happened to
that pilot.
We do have new pilot of what
appears to be a Russian hideout
that was destroyed and Russian
fighters basically moving in
between homes and then, you know
the Ukrainians, they filmed it.
The drones see it, it was
spotted and you'll see the
massive fireball in the
neighborhood as you see.
Russia's losses that they are
sustaining in this way in place
after place along the front line
is partly why Russia is --
you'reeing a big ramp up in
recruitment exforts anecdotally
on the ground and we have video
of young children being taught
to be prepared to fight.
These are children in annexed
crimea and that girl is fast and
they're learning biological
training and Wagner has its own
youth club in St. Petersburg and
there are kids who now
reportedly attend there and are
able to use drone simulators,
reportedly.
We do see it turning to its
youngest and there are
recruiting efforts in schools
and boys as it faces mounting
losses on the battlefield.
Melissa bell is out front
tonight.
>> Wagner fighters at an
industrial plant inside bakhmut.
They are making very gradual
advances, but at a huge cost.
>> This soldier says Ukrainian
forces have vast amounts of
ammunition and are heavily
shelling the area.
We can't even raise our heads,
he says.
Wagner has been trying to take
bakhmut for two months and may
now be running short of
fighters.
Its boss, yevgeny prigozhin has
lashed out at the Russian
defense ministry for starving
his men of ammunition.
>> Translator: We need the
military to shield the
approaches if they manage to do
so everything will be okay.
If not, then Wagner will be
encircled together with the
Ukrainians inside bakhmut.
>> In his latest social media
post, prigozhin praised honest
Russian soldiers and claimed,
quote, unprofessional scoundrels
and intriguers crush these
modest guys and begin to push
them around and humiliate them.
Yet another dive at the military
hierarchy in Moscow.
Prigozhin has accused the
defense mippistry of
incompetence and corruption and
compared his own almost
continuous present in bakhmut to
the notable absence of sergei
shoigu.
Prigozhin, once a Putin ally and
nicknamed Putin's chef is a man
under pressure.
He recruited tens of thousands
of Russian men from prisons and
they've endured horrendous
losses, as many as 80% in some
units.
He's dredging for recruits and
his more experienced units are
stretched as they try to
encircle bakhmut.
Western analysts think that
prigozhin has fallen into a trap
laid by shoigu.
A trap designed to weaken both
Wagner and its boss.
Just when Wagner most needs the
support of the Russian military
around bakhmut, it's curiously
absent.
Russia's elite piling out the
oligarch.
Alexei mukin accused prigozhin
of political ambitions and said
he was an incompetent commander
adding, he has exposed the
Wagner fighters to a major rishg
of encirclement from the attack.
He has regarded prigozhin as
Vladimir Putin's licensed
disruptor and if there is an
unsuccessful bid to take bakhmut
he might find himself out in the
cold.
For now, Erin, the battle for
bakhmut continues.
Ukrainians saying it is too
early to draw conclusions one
way or the other in this ongoing
battle.
What is also unclear at this
stage is what happens with the
battle within the battle and
whether yevgeny prigozhin can
come out unscathed.
Erin?
>> Melissa, thank you very much
from Ukraine.
Out front now, major general
James "Spider" marks.
Can Putin afford to let the
Wagner group totally fail?
>> No, he can't.
He doesn't want them to fail.
I tell you, Melissa's report was
really phenomenal, the levels of
detail and the analysis and the
relationships and the
interknifing and fighting that
ostensibly takes place within
Putin's hierarchy.
It's not frightening.
It's to be expected, I guess.
It's a imga of thrones kind of
environment.
Putin can't afford to lose the
Wagner group, and I will tell
you, if he were to lose
prigozhin someone else would
step up and they'd be recruited
in and that individual would go
about the business of creating a
contract force not unlike the
Wagner group.
The money exists and they'll
find the recruits and they're
going to pay folks.
They have the money to buy the
kit and the individuals and that
doesn't mean they have the
training.
So I think Putin's got himself a
legitimate problem here having
much freedom into prigozhin's
hand.
>> You know what's interesting?
I spoke to a Ukrainian soldier
in bakhmut and he told us
something he heard about and it
still sort of stuns to imagine
that the Wagner forces literally
run into machine gun fire and
they die en masse.
Here's what he said.
>> I can't believe that people,
a real person can run without
afraid to die, without no
recitation and they see the
fellows falling down and they
continue running.
Wagner have only -- only one
chance to survive is to take our
position, our trenches.
That's all.
They have no choice to return to
the position because they will
be killed from their fellows.
>> I mean, it is amazing to hear
him say it, right?
That, you know, and then I
realized the key to their
success because they can't turn
around.
They know they're going to die.
So their best shot is to run
into machine gun fire.
>> Yeah.
There is a distinct difference
between a Ukrainian soldier who
is fighting for the sovereignty
and Independence of his nation
and the Russian conscripted and
the contracted Wagner group
individual.
Russian -- I'm sorry, the
Ukrainian soldier is going to
fight for his buddies.
He's fighting for his
organization.
He's fighting for those on his
left and his right and that
individual is more frightened
about letting them down than he
is potentially dying in combat.
The ones that are working for
Wagner know that the end state
will be death of some sort so
they really don't care.
They are frightened of dying,
but they are more frightened to
be shot in the head if they are
to return.
You have professional soldiers,
vis-a-vis, the conscripted
killers with no motivation other
than the threat from a boss,
effectless, horrible leadership.
They're going to end their lives
one way or the other so they
have no choice.
>> That's just stunning.
>> It really is just incredible